largas filas por un tubo de oxígeno es
colapso en manaos la ciudad más grande
de la amazonía lanzó a las personas a la
búsqueda desesperada de estos cilindros
para sus familiares hospitalizados con
kobe 19
es para mi abuela que está ingresada en
el hospital se le está acabando el
último cilindro y no sé a qué horas
llegaré aquí pero creo que lo voy a
conseguir
estamos buscando la manera de llegar a
la puerta para recibir un tubo para al
menos una semana de vida de una persona
el nivel récord de hospitalizaciones
provocó que ya no haya camas de cuidados
intensivos ni oxígeno en los centros de
salud por eso el gobierno federal
dispuso el traslado de 235 pacientes a
otras ciudades y el envío de oxígeno a
través de la fuerza aérea para el
presidente añadir bolsonaro en los
hospitales de manaus siempre están
llenos defendió su gestión y
responsabilizó a las autoridades locales
siempre estamos haciendo lo que tenemos
que hacer
el problema en manaos es terrible pero
nosotros hemos hecho nuestra parte
ofreciendo recursos pero sus críticos
culpan al mandatario por su escepticismo
en el manejo de la pandemia ocupes y tu
confianza de ahora es culpa del gobierno
federal por la incompetencia la
incapacidad el haber optado por el
negacionismo en relación con esta
pandemia pero me caso new's mi hija la
zona se ha puesto en vida en otro país
esto tal vez sería clasificado como
genocidio brasil mantiene un promedio
de mil fallecimientos diarios y acumula
más de ocho millones de casos las
autoridades federales esperan iniciar la
vacunación con 2 millones de dosis del
fármaco de astrazéneca traídas desde
india un operativo que ha sufrido
atrasos pero calculan concretar en los
próximos dos o tres días